Our discussion of least
mean squares estimation
so far was based
on the case where
we have a single
unknown random variable
and a single observation.
And we're interested
in a point estimate
of this single unknown
random variable.
What happens if we have multiple
observations or parameters?
For example,
suppose that instead
of a single observation, we have
a whole vector of observations.
And, of course,
we assume that we
have a model for
these observations.
Once we observe our
data, a numerical value
for this vector, or what is
the same numerical values
for each one of these
observation random variables.
Then we're placed in the
conditional universe where
these values have been observed.
Then, we notice that the
arguments that we carried out
did not rely in
any way on the fact
that X was one-dimensional.
Exactly the same
argument goes through
for the multi-dimensional
case, and simply, the answer
is again, that the optimal
estimate, the one that
minimizes the mean
squared error, is again,
the conditional expectation
of the unknown random variable
given the values of
the observations.
So this gives us a simple
and much more general
solution that also
applies to the case
of multiple observations.
Now, what if we have
multiple parameters?
Once more, the argument
is exactly the same,
and we obtain that
the optimal estimate
of any particular
parameter is going
to be the conditional
expectation of that parameter
given the observations.
So if our parameter vector
is something of this form,
consisting of
several components,
then the LMS estimate of the
jth component of our parameter
vector is going to be simply
the conditional expectation
of this parameter given the
data that we have obtained.
And this gives us the
most general solution
to the program of
least mean squares
estimation when we have
multiple parameters
and multiple observations.
One very simple concept that
applies to all possible cases.
Unfortunately, however,
our worries are not over.
Even though LMS estimation
has such a simple and such
a general solution, things
are not always easy.
Let us see what's happening.
No matter what, we
have to first find out
the posterior
distribution of Theta
given the observations
that we have obtained.
And this is done using the Bayes
rule, which we have written
here, and this is
how you evaluate
the denominator in Bayes' rule.
What are the difficulties
that we may encounter?
One first difficulty is
that in many applications,
we do not necessarily
have a good model
or we're not very
confident about our model
of the observations.
If X and Theta are
multi-dimensional,
such a model might be
difficult to construct.
Setting this issue aside,
there's a further issue.
The conditional
expectation of Theta
given X may be a complicated
non-linear function
of the observations.
This means that it may
be difficult to analyze,
but even more
important, it may be
very difficult to
calculate even after you
have obtained your data.
Let us understand why
this might be the case.
Suppose that Theta is a
multi-dimensional parameter.
Then in order to calculate the
denominator that's involved
here in the Bayes rule, when you
integrate with respect to theta
, you have to actually carry
a multi-dimensional integral,
and this can be very
challenging or sometimes,
practically impossible.
Even if you had this
denominator term in your hands,
still, in order to calculate
a conditional expectation,
you would have to
calculate once more
an integral of
theta j integrated
against the posterior
distribution of the vector
theta.
But this integral should be once
more, over all the parameters.
So it would be a
multi-dimensional integral
in the general case, and
that's one additional source
of difficulty.
And this is the reason
why we will also
consider an alternative to least
mean squares estimation, which
is much simpler
computationally and much less
demanding in terms
of the model that we
need to have in our hands.